hi I'm Lauria I'm Merle and we are we're
dating
mostly Shane correct Edouard yes there's
pronounced that way because I felt the
front do you ard oh she loves ramen his
favorite food is this like pasta with
clams bustable I made a vegan version of
it recently it was fantastic in your
downtime yeah like you like to watch
movies and nap mm-hmm she loves to hike
okay we actually both have the same
favorite band we both left queen yeah
today where we basically organize these
little mystery boxes we only had a
hundred dollars each to surprise each
other with so we're gonna go ahead and
open those up I think yours is better
I'm nervous no here's hopeless hopeless
romantic oh you're a great gift giver -
I want to go first go in say look it's
the back with Merle and I first started
talking at the office we would exchange
a lot of notes one of the notes that was
sent to me every stardate he was both
kind of cute but quite raunchy too and
for a while I've been meaning to frame
it and give it to her okay I know this
is like the whole point of this is to be
really sweet and gift-giving and sincere
but kind of sick I'm going in Santa
Claus right now I'm right now at a Thai
sweet shop where Merle and I you'd like
to get some snacks
yes these are layer cakes vegan I grew
up in Thailand eat movies all the time I
introduced them tomorrow and she's
addicted to them I found this local
camera ari and I are going on a trip to
Joshua Tree this weekend so I figured
this to be the purple perfect little
gift I don't say perfect it's fine if
you do all right I saw Merle go into a
shirt store I think she's planning on
buying me a shirt for me she's actually
gonna be the one wearing the shirt I
said steal my property I didn't want to
buy this Bowie's shirt because then she
could still wear my Queens shirt because
she loves David Bowie okay so the second
thing I got for aria is this adorable
little Freddie Mercury thin because
queen is both of our favorite band and
we bonded over that when we first met so
one of the first videos Ari and I did
together was friends compare what's in
each other's bags and I had a pair of
underwear in my bag
it was only fitting that he has to
reveal something similarly intimate okay
it will be popular for a very specific
thing called Underberg it is a German
natural herb bitter and the reason why
I'm buying this umbrella ties because
they've over the story behind it I found
a real score here dollar fifty I got
these llama socks one of the things I
bought online for Merle that just
arrived is anti snore chinstrap it's not
for her for me because this poor woman
has to injure me snoring the last thing
I would have Amuro online was something
a little bit more meaningful I think
slowly after I started dating Merle
officially unfortunately her cat passed
away it was an old cat named Rhys and
Merle had her cremated
amuro's always mentions and said how
she's always been kind of unsure what to
do with the ashes one idea that Merle
has brought up in the past of maybe even
playing Reese's ashes in a necklace I
found a necklace online where you could
put ashes inside okay another score I
found this Schrute farm and all right
loves the office okay I've circled back
I'm gonna get him this Dunder Mifflin
shirt hello its me the indecisive lady
and I've gotten even more indecisive
since the last time we chatted I now
found this Michael Scott Paper Company
shirt and I think this is the winner
because we always said that we were
Michael and Holly over Jim and Pam even
though he saw people saying that they
thought we were Jim and pin we're
totally Michael and Holly because
they're weird it's the last couple of
things I got are these stickers these
glitter stickers this puzzle are you a
saying that he wants to do a puzzle okay
and on a sentimental not I got this blow
dryer because Aria actually believer not
takes longer to get ready in the morning
than I do
yeah look at that beautiful headshot
that's worth a lot more than $100 this
is a limited-edition headshot that I
took when I was 17 years old I left a
little note to thank her for her support
I think the great
I shall really cherish all right it's
time to swap so I'm gonna go first
we're usable yes use something reusable
so I flew my hand in here know what that
is the reason why I'm assuming you can
this to me isn't because you think hey I
have bad breath but because when we
spend the night at each other's places
in the morning sometimes more a little
morning smooch I would like to pop one
of these bad boys in
more specifically Aria is very very keen
on always having mints around sometimes
you know this is a woman oh oh they're
significant dates oh sweet this is this
is our anniversary
you need to go through all these I feel
like wasn't taken lightly I told her I
loved her
yeah it's true January 6th you honor us
with puzzles I love puzzles you love big
things in here hefty oh this is great to
stop my hair my hair is a pain yeah for
some reason she doesn't have one of
these at her place so I usually have to
haul mine over to hers but now it's
gonna be permanently there yeah stickers
look at this I got this for fun I
thought we could put them on while we're
doing this well the world is this oh you
know why the reason why is because one
of the I think the very first video we
were in together that wasn't one of ours
I did a couple of men and women repair
each other's back yeah at the very top
of her is the first thing she pulled out
of her bag or apparently my accent the
complete accident looks almost a little
bit such a no mosh and then oh this is
very sweet socks there's actually two
layers to this then actually they're
llamas she says I have llama eyes
either way the other layer to this I'm
assuming is because we have Locke
wrestling matches season all right
anyways very sweet Michael Scott Paper
Company we all of the office we always
say that we're Michael and Holly not Jim
and Pam because in the comments agent of
ham it's come on you don't camera kind
of bland we're weird and fun yeah you
have a Kodak
Oh again for a trip and we got a pin
here Oh a freddy pin that's very cute we
just talked about how much we love Queen
I'm very happy this is wonderful this is
the most the sweetest one was the first
one I open how funny how that works out
so I'm going to protest for one yes we
reusable recycle I would encourage you
use a reusable like a cloth yes yes guys
reach out thank yous reach out for each
other
this is very valuable this is arias
headshot that he's sold that it like an
adult-film convention or something in a
video that he did I the turkey are you
at 14 years old 17 hope my girl anyways
oh okay an anti snore chin strap because
Aria what a dreamboat but let me tell
you this man can wake an entire house up
with yeah put it on the dog what is this
oh my god wait this is from the day we
got drunk together after the cocktails
they only could clip it on a shot I
think yeah pull it up are we to do um
yes I'm never gonna make you wear that
Cheers 44% that's a shot oh one of the
notes that Brown said to me it was both
kind of cute but quite raunchy too this
is a framed pornographic sketch that I
made for our you one time those are
stick figures doing that reverse cowgirl
how can you cut me sure yeah David Bowie
I love David Bowie labyrinth is one of
my favorite movies but I also obviously
love his music is there's this cute
little Thai sweet shop that we go to and
we get these bananas wrapped in sticky
rice and we get these little jelly layer
cake things they're both vegan so I can
beat them there's a reason behind this
you oh no I have to tell you but for a
while you said you might want to put
Reese's ashes at a necklace did you do
it I didn't do it I don't have her ashes
ashes I'm actually crying
I win you win I knew you would win I
knew you had something in there that was
gonna make me cry Rhys is my cat she was
17 half years old she came with me
across the country and she passed away
and so I got a cremated and I don't know
what to do with her ashes so I said I
wanted to meet
something anyway so now I can put in
this oh that's so sweet you fix my tears
that's gonna take a long that's great
thank you so much oh it was a wonderful
wonderful wonderful wonderful assortment
of gifts how did I do it do you hate it
no you did wonderfully I don't see it
worn my heart a lot because honestly
just shows how much you know about me
and that's that's why I love about doing
this video is that what is what a fun
way to show how much we know about each
other all these were wonderful and I
really loved receiving each of them
there was thought behind each of them
and I think that's what this whole video
was kind of a nice exercise which was
that yeah there was thought behind each
gift it was a nice exercise to like
really think about our relationship and
kind of a quiet little gift to each
emotion so I'm happy we did it was fun
I'm very happy we did it - yeah I'm
definitely warm I'm I read a little bit
more warm so got a few more hours of
work
[Music]